juan williams on on fox news i actually
really like juan williams
he's always been very nice to me and i
find a lot of his commentary
at least thought provoking but he gave a
pretty weak answer the other day he was
he was asked about that awful carjacking
of those two
young girls who there was two young
black girls who carjack a pakistani guy
and then kill him and then callously
they just don't care at all they walk
past they walk
back to the crime scene past his dead
body because one of the girls forgot her
cell phone in the car
and this topic was brought up in a
discussion and juan williams
tried to find every elaborate answer
except for the obvious one
i think in part what it is is you got
it's tragic i mean you got these
teenage girls i mean they're little kids
not they're not
gangsters they're not hardened criminals
i don't think they intended to kill
anybody they were looking for have a joy
ride
and it just went way wrong way out of
control and ended up in a
gross tragedy i mean this is
unbelievable their lives are ruined
well they brought a stun gun and so
usually you don't bring a stun gun
to a joy ride but go i just think
correct i mean it's like you know kids
finding guns in their parents
i don't know what to say jesse it's
awful it's a terrible situation
so the question is why would these girls
do it and juan's answer is
you know that maybe maybe they weren't
trying to
carjack the guy and maybe they actually
weren't just callously disregarding his
life maybe they wanted to go for a joy
ride
and then jesse waters says well you know
they brought a stun gun with them
yeah well maybe they yeah and maybe
their parents just left that around and
maybe
they maybe was all a big accident maybe
it's all a big misunderstanding maybe
they're really good kids
maybe the simplest answer is the correct
one maybe they're just
bad kids and we all have fallen broken
nature
and some people turn out worse than
others and maybe they they're
they just did a very evil thing because
they had evil motivations and they don't
care about human life and they at the
very least need to be locked up forever
there there's this concept of occam's
razor which
without being too elaborate about it is
this idea that all things being equal
the simplest explanation for a
phenomenon should be preferred to
unnecessarily
complex answers for it
what happened to that in our culture why
can't we get back to occam's culture
why is it that if i look at a little boy
and he looks like a little boy
and he he has all the body parts of a
little boy and his dna is that of a
little boy
why do i have to be confused about that
and say well we don't know
why why can't we just accept what is
obviously
true before our eyes if our country that
we are now told is the worst country in
the world and it's
the source of evil in the world and we
need to destroy our country and open up
the borders and we owe everything to
everybody
why is it that everyone from the rest of
the world wants to come here why is it
that
we why is it that we have to have such a
robust security system on our on our
border
why is it that millions of people come
here every single year is it possible
that the simplest solution is the
correct one
is it possible that we're just a good
country and an attractive place to live
and
and have your life and raise your family
is that possible
no somehow we are preferring
the the most ridiculous rube goldberg
complex answers to the common sense
that and the obvious solutions that we
can see before
our very eyes if you enjoyed that video
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you